[Applause]
uh
thank you so much first i i uh
first thing i want to say is i love you
back
sits that's it uh
first thing i want to say is clearly my
mother snuck in here
cause that [ __ ] intro was ridiculous
i'm sorry you had to sit through that
[ __ ] um
[Music]
jesus uh
i'll get to it i'll get to it um
okay so i don't i don't have unlimited
time so i want to
get right into it couple things i want
to talk about first and foremost
i am so fired up to be here i've never
spoken
in this market so thank you so much for
the warm welcome
[Applause]
to be very frank the thing that i'm
thinking most about
when i think about the lineup of
speakers is
why are you here right to me when you
speak
what matters most is can you bring value
to the audience
and so i've been thinking quite a bit
about this speech
of like what can i really touch on that
isn't available for free
online that isn't something you've seen
or heard before
and the reality is is that's a difficult
challenge
in a world where very honestly there's
not a lot that i believe in
there's only four to six to nine things
that i really trade on
and those are the things that i want to
really reinforce first and foremost
the biggest thing that i want to make
sure that everybody understands more
than anything
if you know i just had a really fun
strategy session with a bunch of people
and when i think about what it was that
we just talked about for the last couple
hours
is the fact of the matter is i truly
believe
that every single person here today
including myself are grossly
underestimating how special
today is how special this era
of the internet at maturity is
how special the opportunity is what what
what is remarkable to me this morning is
that
there is never and i mean this now if
you are somebody who watches
cable news all day you may not agree
with me
but it is my absolute deep belief
that this is the greatest era to be
alive in human race
and i'll tell you why this internet
thing
it's bigger than you think this internet
thing
when you're older when our great great
grandkids
judge us and how we navigated through
this era
this internet thing is a much bigger
deal than we've been able to comprehend
the internet not facebook not social
media
not instagram not podcasting the
internet is the
single biggest invention that has ever
happened to the human race
and we being in it in the first couple
decades of it
are struggling to understand how big of
a deal it is
what i am completely [ __ ] blown away
by is that there is nobody
and i mean nobody who is a gatekeeper
to the game anymore what is amazing to
me
is that our great great grandparents our
great
grandparents and our grandparents would
laugh at the [ __ ] that we cry about
the amount of people that get upset that
instagram and facebook changed their
algorithm
and cry about it is [ __ ] ludicrous
[Music]
it's free facebook and instagram
are free and we sit and cry about the
change in an algorithm
here's where i'm at for this entire room
the one thing that connects all of us
whether you're an entrepreneur whether
you work somewhere whether you're
[ __ ] thrilled
whether you're devastated the one thing
that connects all of us
is that for us to take the step in what
we're trying to achieve
whether it's financial whether it's
legacy whatever it may be
the one thing that connects us is we
have to trade on attention
the thing that i desperately want
everybody to leave this talk with
is understanding that attention is
just like real estate and that attention
is the gateway drug to everything you
want period
before you can tell me how great you are
how awesome what you're selling is
you need my attention before you can
tell me anything you need my attention
what everybody in this room needs to
wrap their head around is that
this device owns the attention of our
society
you may be upset about it you might be
sad that when you go out people aren't
talking to each other
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want it
doesn't change
the fact that this has the attention
and if you are sitting in this room
today and you have not figured out how
to put written words
audio or video into the platforms that
sit on top of this
you were fundamentally irrelevant
[Applause]
and so when you think about sitting here
and standing here
look i have no interest in inspiring you
for an
hour and getting you pumped and then
next thursday you don't do
[ __ ] about it that's not interesting to
me
i'll be very frank even with all these
faces in the audience
i'm looking for one person who
understands
that this is such a remarkable time and
that you need to go
harder at it let me tell you let me tell
you
let me tell you the thing that upset me
most in my intro
i'm extremely proud maybe more than
anything
that i went into my family business and
built my family business for my family
i'm proud i love when people try to razz
on me easy for you
you you were handed a three million
dollars when they don't know my story
what i was handed was my dad had a
liquor store doing three million dollars
a year
on 10 profit and what i did was work my
face off 17 hours a day
from 22 to 34 building my dad's
business for my dad and my mom and at 34
years old
i left wine library day to day with zero
percent equity in wine library and no
money in my bank that's what i did
i'm proud you know if you're if you're a
child of an
immigrant or great parents nothing is
better
than settling the score with your
parents so
that's like i wish i can't zoom in but
the goosebump can you just confirm this
like real [ __ ] goosebumps
the best meanwhile when the intro came
up
the gentleman said he grew his dad's
business from four to sixty million
true nice solid accomplishment also
my greatest regret if i could do it
again
business-wise i would have built wine
library from a four to a 250 million
dollar business in that same time
let me tell you why and let me tell you
why it's the only thing you need to pay
attention to in my entire talk
let me break this down get your [ __ ]
attention
up right now i don't know if you like
taking notes i don't know how you like
to consume it
but i promise you what i'm going to
explain for the next three minutes is
the [ __ ] game
right now i built my dad's business from
four to sixty million dollars with no
money the business was doing four
million dollars
400 400 000 in profit before expenses
we literally had no money right you pay
people you pay your rent
like nothing my first year marketing
budget
in building wine library was 14 000 for
the year
in marketing i was able to build it
in such a big way for three core reasons
in 1996 nobody had a website
that was a good idea number two i
started an
email newsletter and you know for the
youngsters in here
you know it's hard to understand but you
have to understand people didn't even
know their own email when they would
come into the wine store i'd ask them
you want to be on the email list they'd
be like yeah i'm like what's your email
they're like
aol yahoo.com i'm like no [ __ ]
like this was early this was early but i
started an email newsletter how many
people here have done email marketing in
their career raise your hand
i had 91 open rates on my email
newsletter in 1997 and 8.
why not because it was such good content
all it said was buy this [ __ ] merlot
it was because nobody else was emailing
and i bought that real estate cheap
because nobody else was doing it
and then the final point of why i really
exploded my business was the day that
google adwords
came out i bought google adwords for my
dad's business
so i was the first result for wine and
cabernet
and napa valley and while everybody else
was doing direct mail
and advertising in magazines and radio i
was winning google
which went on to become google got it
let me now explain to you the number one
mistake every person in this audience is
making right now
including me who's supposed to be fancy
at this
every person in this place is not
producing enough content for social
media
and is not spending enough money on
social media ads
every person in here is not producing
enough content
and not spending enough ad money on
social media because you have to
understand what's about to happen
let me explain it real simple right now
buying ads on
instagram and facebook which is
something everybody in here should be
doing
at scale and please don't be that person
that has run facebook and instagram ads
and not gotten results
and deemed it not working the roi of a
basketball to me
is zero the roi of a basketball
to lebron is billions of dollars if you
have nothing
how many people here and let's be honest
with each other how many people here
have run
facebook or instagram ads and it hasn't
worked raise your hand
actually stand up i want everybody to
see this don't be lazy do this for
everybody
watch this keep going don't sit down yet
everybody look around all these people
suck i'm kidding i'm kidding sit down
sit down
guys please understand this truth
everybody that stood up and i'm not
joking
you haven't made instagram and facebook
ads work for you
because you either hired somebody who's
not good at it or you're not good at it
this debate is not a debate they work
and they work so well that it's scary
so scary that the [ __ ] founder has to
sit in front of congress
seriously i i i'm laughing at people
people
go out to dinner with me old ceos and
yell at me for the first 30 minutes that
facebook's killing our democracy
and then the next 30 minutes tell me
that it doesn't sell [ __ ]
like everybody's so scared of it yet you
don't think it works to sell
guys this is the most powerful ad
product we have seen
since the early days of television
commercials so when i see that many
people stand up
please get educated plea and you have to
understand why it's so awesome
you can run 25 and 50 at a time to get a
sense of if it's working
also the biggest mistake in this room is
you're confused between the business
of branding and selling the
number one basic issue in business right
now that i've been blown away by because
it came natural to me i'm like oh [ __ ]
wait a minute
people are confusing branding and
selling the amount of people that just
stood up
that it didn't work for they spent money
to make a transaction
it didn't happen they stood up and said
it didn't work
what they don't realize is first of all
the creative is the variable
if i stand up here today i've got all of
your attention
that's a victory if this keynote sucks
[ __ ]
i've accomplished nothing i've
accomplished
negative impact if you live here
disappointed of like ah he's not that
good live ah he's stupid
lost this was a waste of time that's
just like an ad
you can get in front of me at a good
price but if you're trying to sell me
too hard and you come off like a
douchebag
you've lost if you haven't convinced me
why your banana
jelly is better than somebody jesus
christ where does this [ __ ] come from
the [ __ ] is banana jelly
somebody's gonna [ __ ] start a banana
jelly company here i know it
if you haven't convinced me that your
banana jelly is better than my
competitor's banana jelly then you're
not gonna buy it
please understand this let me break it
down very simply
it's why i set it up as the most
important thing everybody here
needs to spend money whether you're a
lawyer financial advisor
sports trainer nutritionist you
cut you you have a concrete if your
company
paves people's [ __ ] driveways you
need to run facebook and instagram ads
it is the most underpriced attention in
our society
and let me tell you why as i stand here
today and regret
not spending more money on google
adwords everybody in here will regret
in four years i promise you if nothing
else i'm being very selfish right now
in this advice i'm being very selfish
i'm making a very big deal that you're
not spending enough money in this
platform
because i want you to remember in four
years when you don't spend enough money
in this platform
and you actually have your eureka moment
and realize how right i was
i want you to remember of [ __ ] i should
have listened to garyvee in florida
right now facebook and instagram ads run
between three and eight dollar
cpms between three and eight dollars you
can get in front of a thousand people's
streams
not a thousand see it you know how you
roll through your stream
over the next five years when the
biggest companies in the world
like nike and bmw and ibm
when they really realize how bad
television commercials are
and how good this is they're gonna pour
their money in what is gonna happen
the same [ __ ] that happened to me on
google i used to buy the word
wine and cabernet and pinot noir for
five cents a click
now it's four and eleven and eighteen
dollars
a click that [ __ ] adds up
at the same token the way the ads work
is gonna decline
in the beginning when i was running
facebook and instagram three years ago
it did better than it does now
because you're getting more [ __ ] now and
you're starting to tune it out
open rates on email went from 90 to 30
this is one big game of cops and robbers
this is one big game of cat and mouse
when everybody here figures out that
they should be doing it and everybody
does it
it becomes more noise and that's the
[ __ ] game
right now what you're doing with your
allocation of content
and ad spend on facebook and instagram
is the same thing that happens in real
estate
when somebody knows they need to buy or
debated to buy something in a hot up and
coming area
they don't their friends did
it went to up it happened then they get
sad
they get another chance to invest for
150 000 more
but because they [ __ ] up and passed at
150 000 less
they say no again six months later it
keeps blowing up now it's up three
hundred thousand
now you're like [ __ ] again because
you've passed twice
this is the story of uber for me i
passed on uber's angel round
twice how many people have read
or have crush it my first book if you go
back and look at it
i acknowledge in the acknowledgments i
thank my family
and one random person travis the
co-founder of uber that's it
i passed on one of my best business
friends
startup twice at a four million dollar
valuation
and he was one of my best buds and it
went on to become uber
i was writing 25 and 50 000
checks back then if i wrote one of my
normal checks back then
into uber that investment would have
paid me 400 million dollars
i'm not sad i'm not
i'm being dead serious i don't give a
[ __ ] about the money i give a [ __ ] about
the freedom of playing the game
understand if you're a true bread
entrepreneur in this audience you're not
in it for the money
you're in it for the game i actually
love
that i passed on uber twice i'm being
serious
[Applause]
the quickest tell for me in five minutes
when i hang with somebody if they're
true bread or if they're
not is are they in it for the game or do
they want to buy a watch
so here's the story of uber though
i used to pass on investments they would
blow up a little bit and then i wouldn't
invest
again because i was salty because i
passed on it at four and now i didn't
want to put money at it
at 60. i'd learned that lesson and thank
god because when uber came back around i
did invest in it
not as early and this crazy but i made a
lot a lot of money and made the right
decision
because i left my emotions out of the
table got it
a lot of you are not going on social
media harder because some of your
friends have more followers and you
don't have the humility to start now
and start at a low base you're not doing
it because you tried it
and it's not worked in the past and you
don't get it what is happening right now
is very simple attention is the only
thing that matters for anything you try
to do
there's a reason i was born in the
soviet union right
i know you know last night i hung out
with a bunch of great people from
venezuela right
[Music]
jesus this is actually fun
who's from chicago
[Applause]
who's from sweden this is forget it
who's from texas
[Applause]
all right jersey yeah
all right anyway belarus
[Applause]
grandpa
my friends i have very little to say
life is basic
99 of this audience is doing [ __ ]
because they value somebody else's
opinion more than their own
if i sat down with all of you one by one
i could figure out every dumb thing
you're doing and trace it back to you're
doing it
to impress somebody or to prove somebody
wrong it's the biggest mistake you can
make
and if you leave here with anything the
second you can get quiet in here
and stop worrying about the judgment of
others the second [ __ ] starts actually
happening
that gets even harder in today's new
world of living publicly
it's true now i like the motivation of a
chip on his shoulder i love that i
post my report card and i was ranked 243
out of 254 in my entire class
and i find it really fun and exciting
that
my mission now is to create more wealth
and success than the rest of my [ __ ]
class combined
but that shouldn't be the reason you do
things right and so
there's a couple things that i want to
break through in this meeting today
number one
is why do you do what you do because way
too many people are doing it from a
place of defense
and i'm trying to figure out every day
how to produce content or have a
conversation
of getting you to do it for yourself for
yourself
how many people saw rocky iv the russian
one
super interesting it has nothing to do
with the fact that i was born in belarus
and former soviet union it's a very
different reason why i like this moment
in the end of that movie the most
interesting part is what drago says
after he loses rocky wins and then they
take the mic
and you know rocky does the whole like
we can be friends [ __ ]
which worked for a few minutes um but
what was way more important is what
drago said
which is he said i didn't fight rocky
for this country i fought him for myself
and i was a young kid when that movie
came out and it has stuck with me
forever
some of you consume my content and know
i talk a lot about
i don't care what you think about my
losses
my l is my l you're more than welcome to
leave a comment and clown on me when i
fail on something when something doesn't
work out
i have good news for you i don't give a
[ __ ] what you have to say
[Applause]
in the session i just had we were
talking about this [ __ ] i was like look
because i think facebook and instagram
is so underpriced and i want you to pour
money into it i'm trying to convince
people to sell their homes
and live in an apartment and take the
money and reinvest in their business
because nobody takes advantage of all
six of their bedrooms when they buy a
six bedroom home
we live in three [ __ ] rooms
everybody's doing [ __ ] for the outside
you wear the clothes for the outside
you floss you front and it's the biggest
[ __ ] mistake you make
i've been inside my own head for a long
time on the back of really good
parenting
and circumstance the great advantage of
being born with nothing and being an
immigrant
is you told and you were told from the
get that you suck and you lost
and that is the advantage
the disadvantage is entitlement
how many people here have kids raise
your hand cool you want to do a real
favor for your kids stop protecting them
eighth place trophies leads to dumb [ __ ]
[Applause]
losing my whole life is the greatest
[ __ ] thing that happened
i cried every time my mom was happy
about it
this is a very simple binary game in
life
and in business you are either on the
offense or you're on the defense
way too many of you are sitting here
right now and thinking you're in the
middle there is no middle
you're either going backwards or you're
going forwards there's no [ __ ]
neutral in the way that we live this
to me education is the game but not the
way it's packaged in our society today
[ __ ] school the way we have it now [ __ ]
it
that doesn't mean education's not the
game what did i do in the first seven
minutes of my
talk here i'm trying to educate listen
to me [ __ ]
listen carefully if you're not producing
words videos or pictures for instagram
facebook podcasting youtube
linkedin and that world you don't
[ __ ] exist
nor does your business listen
listen and do not have the wrong kpi
it's not how many likes or followers you
have i have a funny feeling here
if you got one follower and one like but
you were getting what you wanted
for the content that you put out
financially or emotionally you'd be
super happy
do not get caught up in the micro game
of social
people always roll up and be like i have
a million followers i'm like so
like what are you doing with that
attention what are you trying to
accomplish and what is your goal
and by the way you want to make money
mazel tov you want to change the world
mazel tov i have no interest in judging
your ambition
my interest is in are you relevant in
may
2018. are you relevant
in may 2018 i don't care people are
garyvee what's the next
[ __ ] big platform i don't know dick
i'm not [ __ ] nostradamus up here
i don't know what the next big platform
is i know what platform's working right
now
i know that youtube is working right now
i know that facebook's working right now
i know that none of you because if i'm
not all in with somebody who's got 22
full-time employees now
up from one in three years working on my
content if i know in my heart
that i'm pouring millions and have 22
full-time people making written words
audio and video and i can feel it as i
stand on the stage
that i'm not even close to putting in
enough chips the [ __ ] are you doing
[Applause]
this is the most selfish keynote i've
ever given i'm being serious
i am putting a deep deep [ __ ] flag in
the ground telling you right now
that if you post once a day on instagram
make it for
if you don't post on twitter start if
you stopped posting on snapchat stories
because instagram has that feature too
you're a [ __ ] idiot
and guess what all of you did it
attention is the asset everything you
aspire for
why am i building vaynermedia i'm
building it because i want to build an
attention
death star and if i need to point that
at
curing a disease that my mom gets one
day or helping my best friend become the
governor of
florida or to sell sneakers or to make
all of you a jets fan
even though you don't know it's what i'm
doing to you right now
that's fine go look at my post three
posts ago on instagram
i love when you [ __ ] boomy dicks
[Applause]
don't get it twisted negative
reinforcement is the strength
fake positivity leads to an awfully bad
place here
and that's what's going on in the system
really your self-esteem is wrapped up in
how many likes you get
really this is no
question the second best time
in the internet era in the last 20 years
and it lives on three apps four apps on
this phone
and none of us are doing enough reps
more reps i don't care what the history
of your content and ads have been
on these platforms whatever it was is
yesterday
get yourself educated go home go on
google
and type in how do i run instagram ads
go home go on google and run how do i
run
pre-roll youtube ads based on people's
google search query
go home and dm 100 influencers on
instagram
and ask them how much it costs for them
to give you a shout out
for whatever the [ __ ] you're selling the
quicker you become a practitioner
do you know many people in this room
have opinions on facebook and instagram
ads
but i've never run one
too much headline reading not enough
[ __ ] doing
i can't say it enough the reason this is
the most selfish
keynote i've ever given is because i'm
putting a flag in the ground and telling
you that everybody in this room needs to
do way more content
on these social networks because it is
where the attention is it's where the
underpriced attention is
and it is 100 how you're going to get to
where you want to get to
period end of story there is no
advertising
there's content put in front of people
that create an event
and i just am trying as you can tell in
this talk to squeeze the [ __ ] out of it
because let me educate you in
non-tuition form
who was the biggest advertiser in google
adwords in the first five or six years
of the platform
amazon amazon today
no question is one of the one two or
three most powerful companies in the
world
on the back of amazing things that bezos
did
but do not get confused the most
important one
he and it bet heavy
on underpriced attention you know who
else bet on underpriced attention
muhammad ali you know who else elvis
presley
and the beatles and basically everybody
else you know
you know why you know who martin luther
king is because he was a media
savant there was a lot of people spit in
truth
he just knew how to get the cameras to
capture it please get smart here today
please get smart here today because
while you're judging
all those people that are winning while
you're judging the paul brothers
while you're judging the fitness
influencers
on instagram while you sit and [ __ ]
judge
people are gobbling up real estate of
attention and are gonna execute on what
they want
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can have all the fun you want
judging
there's a small group out there that's
executing
i am trying to convince one person in
this room to start executing
one just one of the ten thousand of you
i don't need all of you
one how many people are going to be in a
pla you know how many of you are winning
at some level
but you're not reinvesting your money
into it this is the greatest era
instead of the 100 000 in profit that
you're making going into another
vacation
or a [ __ ] supreme bag what about
putting that money
into more instagram ads and facebook ads
because i'm not trying to buy a porsche
i'm trying to buy the porsche [ __ ]
company
now that's me i'm not trying to impose
my ambitions or what i want to do in my
career on you
i'm just trying to get you to understand
one truth there is
one reason i stand up here
it's because i was parented extremely
well but the execution
underneath that is because i've always
had one religion
not money i've had the religion of
attention
because if you have the attention you
can do anything
do you know why p diddy sits on the
spear that he sits on
because when trl had the attention of
every teenager
in america he used to run from his bad
boy office
and crash carson daly's set every day
because he's smart do you know why will
smith is doing what he's doing on
instagram right now
cause he's smart because being a big
movie star
isn't the same thing it was 20 years ago
it doesn't carry
the same attention my friends
it's happened the internet is here
you may not want to put in the work
that's fine
but it's just like fitness you can't
read
about doing push-ups
you got to do them
[Applause]
i'm gonna leave you with this because
they're buzzing me off i'm gonna leave
you with this
no don't cheer remember i like the booze
i'll just leave right the [ __ ] now
let me just position it like this guys
here's where i'm at
400 trillion to one i know some of you
know i'm obsessed with this
i can't wrap my head around the fact
that it's basically impossible to become
a human being
there's nothing you'll ever do that is
more remarkable or harder
than actually being lucky enough to and
like you can't imagine
the math behind you actually being a
person
my question is since you've won the
ultimate lottery
like what are you doing about it because
way too many people in this room are
dwelling about yesterday
that shit's over and so if i can leave
you with anything
it's very high and low i've spent a good
amount of my conversation here
pushing you very aggressively to
something practical
i wasn't here to rah-rah and tell you
like the
one [ __ ] thing
run some [ __ ] ads make more content
dick that's what i'm here to say
[Applause]
but but because i genuinely believe that
optimism is a strategy
i just desperately need you to know that
no matter what you complain about your
grandparents had it worse
no matter what the [ __ ] about to come
out of your mouth your grandparents had
it worse
and if you don't take advantage if
you're not winning
right now in this new world you
really suck and you need to face that
truth
you need to go home look in the mirror
if you're not pumped if you're not
winning by whatever your definition is
i'm telling you this will help you this
i'm not trying to razz you i [ __ ]
want you to win it doesn't come out of
my expense
i need you to win i want you to win why
not if you're not winning right now
you're really losing you're losing more
than anybody's ever lost
and i know that might be like i get it
it's a little bit of a curveball
but here's why i need you to hear it
nobody
is stopping you there's no man
there's no system there's no government
there's nothing it's [ __ ] here i'm
telling you it's [ __ ] here
the internet doesn't give a [ __ ] what
your granddad's last name is
the internet doesn't give a [ __ ] where
you came from doesn't [ __ ] care about
your zip code
it doesn't care about anything execute
on this [ __ ] thing and realize
nobody's stopping you
because what excuses are
is the drug to not do and i
need people to leave complaining you
know why i have a happy life and i'm
going to leave you with this
i don't complain because i don't expect
anything from anybody
right like expectations
are a disaster get it out of the system
go educate yourself and whether you're
selling a t-shirt
or a lifestyle brand or your thoughts on
real estate whatever you're up to
facebook instagram facebook instagram
youtube facebook instagram linkedin
youtube facebook instagram youtube
linkedin
podcast this is real no matter how
you're winning
in direct mail or cold calling or bulk
email or whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
no matter how you're winning there
because i do all those things and
understand them
the fertile ground is much greater here
and when you become a practitioner of it
and you understand how it works
the roi becomes disproportionately
powerful and i promise you
it is going away by the minute because
the second budweiser
and nike actually i'm gonna leave with
this how many people here
how many people here now basically
outside of live sports watch netflix
stand up stand up if you're basically
ott
netflix hulu amazon
this is [ __ ] staggering
i need everybody in the front please
don't sit down yet i need everybody in
the front to look at what i'm looking at
guys abc and cbs and espn are out of
business it's already over
80 billion dollars you can sit because i
gotta wrap up
80 billion dollars in television
commercials
and nobody [ __ ] watches them over the
next three or four to five years the
biggest companies in the world are gonna
understand that
that money is gonna go into the [ __ ]
that i just told you about
that's gonna mean the ads that you're
gonna run are gonna go from four dollars
to eighty dollars
and you're not going to be able to
compete with coca-cola and bmw so please
heed what i told you
take your romance or your subjective
point of view
or you being romantic about how the
world used to be
and shove that [ __ ] in the garbage and
get the [ __ ] work
one life do something about it
kindness
all right i gotta go sorry
[Music]